let's bring in our correspondent
ashnahinaku standing by there for us
this morning a lot of people having to
move their homes ashana good morning
good morning kay a lot of people having
to evacuate their homes it's almost a
miracle really there haven't been any
casualties because of this but the
emergency services have been very quick
to react if i move out of the way you
can take a look at what they have had to
be reacting to we've been told there was
going to be large
seismic activity and that's certainly
the case that spewing volcano is around
four miles away from me but that lava is
shooting up over about a thousand feet
into the night sky you really can't
fathom the speed that that lava is
traveling straight from the center of
the earth those cinders have been
erupting consistently since sunday uh
geologists say these smaller eruptions
have been more frequent over the past
few hours and every so often okay you'll
hear this raw from the volcano even even
though it is about four miles away from
me as i say it's still you do feel the
effects of it and we've been warned that
there will be lava flows perhaps toxic
gas in the air and volcanic ash but
already the roads are covered in that
volcanic ash that black thick a grainy
substance and it's absolutely everywhere
it's it's on the roads it's on your
clothing and it makes you think how much
of it is in the air and how much of
those particles are you breathing in
authorities as i mentioned are going to
be waiting for that first sign of light
there you go that large large plume of
lava spewing out there they will be
waiting for that first sign of light
where they'll probably start to assess
the lasting damage from this
no doubt they've got a huge task on
their hands
very dramatic pictures from la palma
this morning thanks so much indeed